I have really no idea why I'm here I
draw professionally here at BuzzFeed I'm
an animator I actually went to art
school I was bad at drawing the whole
entire time I'm just not really good at
perspective really trash at that drawing
I like going to museums
I like seeing paintings and things like
that but I would not consider myself to
be an artist so whatever I'm about to
draw is probably gonna be bad what super
easy that was a better draw or a painter
I'd really get it done I guess I could
try
okay so first I'm gonna make a torso the
head so I make a little messed up but
it's okay this is her hair in her face
so right now this is her and then I'm
gonna drop I'm just gonna draw the
general outline of Miss Lisa is it okay
if I call her Miss Lisa she doesn't mind
so she's got a face for sure for some
reason the thing about the Mona Lisa is
that she's smiling a little bit right
she's just like she's a little cheeky
people say she smiles but I don't think
she actually smiles but I think she has
a very flat look she looks like she's
annoyed but probably by some old creepy
da Vinci probably some old creepy man no
I don't remember her I live a full life
I pay taxes I'm drawing her in the style
of FAMILY GUY okay maybe I'll draw the
neck now does she have a neck Shirley
woo God look at me such a good artist at
least friend is full she got money she's
like not especially beautiful well let's
work on the background so we got a
little like brown right so the
background I know has like there's like
shrubs and wood wooded stuff but it's
like not very like clear it is okay
guys I'm really bad
I'm really scared that your other face
ignore her family guy gel and like you
just look at that and that is pretty
much the Mona Lisa you squint a little I
don't know if she has boobs but she's
getting them we're gonna give her some
Kylie Jenner lips really was Mona Lisa
and what's her name Mona Lisa
Oh what kind of like did she lead was
she happy what she loves does she find
the love she was looking for I'm done I
think this is as close as I can get
I don't remember you Mona Lisa girl I'm
strong can you show me the real picture
now okay okay
damn okay I wasn't okay wait wait I
wasn't like way wrong it looks like she
has a lace front no no Oh see I feel
like it's kind of there it's like a
cartoon version solid 0.4%
I forgot the arms Leonardo that guy if
he had just one sharpie five minutes and
this I think he could have not done any
better than me you can buy this online
now it's available to you right now for
$6.99 and $0.99 or seven easy payments
of $300 you can send that directly to my
vin mo which is Ryan - Graham again that
is Ryan - Graham and you can have your
very own BuzzFeed Mona Lisa